Danny let me ask you something if you
work man okay I appreciate appreciate
your permission are you shocked by what
you can get away with now on television
versus say when you were on taxi on taxi
was like you know you had all those
people breathing down your neck
like with the ABC NBC their career other
C's got FX FX xx FXX fix fix they don't
breathe down your neck you can do
anything you want anything you want we
do right the more X is the better your
ex is the better right more accent ah
yeah and yeah I think we believe we just
go for it you know do anything like I'd
do anything they say I yeah you do
you literally seem to do anything they
tell you has there ever been a moment
because you are an esteemed actor we've
said no I'm not going to do this this is
beneath me I will not do it no I never
said no to anything I've been slimed
I've been they've painted me black for a
camouflage show I mean I you know I dug
up my dead wife I mean yeah yeah that's
that you're naked a lot and I'm naked
constantly on the show couch naked I
mean all of a sudden I turned into
Willem Dafoe yeah we have a flip montage
here Danny that gives you just a small
taste these are just take a look
[Applause]
wanna be pure
[Music]
you want the baby boys hole you got a
pen
[Applause]
what is this what are you doing
painting a shirt
[Applause]
whoa Ruth let your ass for you don't try
to stop me oh my god
[Applause]
more of the cats of itami Simon could
help
you